iconic she's an artist she is the
history of fashion like no other
designer she's a legend
modern graphic she's explosive
yes I'm sure your gratitude is quite
inexpressible I first encountered Edna's
work I remember sitting in Paris along
diving Mila hmm she's very intimidating
outrageous you love Ashley right Edna's
a divisive figure that cycle in siog
Louie Vuitton Edgar she's a visionary a
giant I mean well not literally she
comes up to my knees my favorite and new
pieces the nuclear ones the rocket
stilettos everyone has said the bees
don't ask me to do it again darling my
rates are far too have you ever heard
anything so different and they can all
pull it off a tall dark and angsty
Elastigirl
Edna designed this know some guy named
Alexander gehlbach I would say
Edna mode is like the modern-day Andy
Warhol but I think Andy Warhol looked up
to her
bravo Bravo darling no bill will be
covered by my feet for being mr.
incredible Elastigirl and frozen's
exclusive designer throughout the known
universe and until the end of time
[Music]
[Music]
is that a new job doing hero work I
couldn't have done this if you hadn't
taken over so well Pixar's Incredibles 2
in theatres June 15
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I thought we were gonna go heard your
mother
trampolining
superheroes are illegal you want to
fight bad guys defines Who I am
we're not saying you have what someone
on TV said I was approached baddest
tycoon most talked-about hero stuff help
me bring supers back into the sunlight
we need Elastigirl
[Music]
kids no problem not the way you're
supposed to do it dad they want us to do
it I don't know that way why would they
change math over Dusseldorf do those are
dogging Kyle is so heavy a troop he
[Music]
closed it I couldn't have done this if
you hadn't taken over so well I've got
to succeed so she can succeed
Bob is tricky but I can't keep giving if
done properly parenting is a heroic act
done properly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you